it's like having things
that's seriously cool and you're totally
doing the walking motion correct exactly
yeah and just with only um 40 of my
weight Jeremy Renner showing off his
healing process after suffering a
snowplow accident in January I really
couldn't be more fortunate on Sunday The
Avengers star shared this clip from a
recent physical therapy session walking
on an assisted treadmill
that's seriously cool and you're totally
only um 40 of my weight Jeremy captioned
the video now is the time for my body to
rest and recover from my will just ready
that's what animal is always ready back
in January the actor was crushed by a
snow cat as he tried to prevent his
nephew from being hurt as it rolled
someone's been run over by a snow cat
hurry he's been crushed okay we have one
paramedics in England everyone's on the
way right now listen to me you might
want to get a life flight out here
immediately the accident left him in
critical condition with 30 plus broken
bones Jeremy also had to undergo chest
surgery for blunt chest trauma and
Orthopedic injuries
yeah no been in touch and reached out to
me soon good I believe and oh yeah all
prayers are with them since the accident
Jeremy's friends and co-stars have
shared updates with E.T Jeremy Renner
have you spoken with him is he in good
spirits how's he doing I talked to him
yesterday yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
he's doing all right he's doing he's
doing well he's the best best guy and
you know
um he's awesome he is a force of nature
he's Unstoppable and I just am so
relieved that he's on the comeback Trail
Jeremy
that was the first shower
I'm definitely weak or so
gross the actor has kept fans in the
loop on his recovery writing that he'll
do whatever it takes to recover
physically and mentally it's nice to
kind of share that part of my life
with people last week he shared this
handwritten note from his nephew which
read in part I am very lucky because my
uncle is Hawkeye
[Music]
I am also very lucky that my uncle is
alive from his accident well seems safe
to say Jeremy is a superhero on the big
screen and IRL you're totally doing the
walking muscle crap yeah and just with
only um 40 of my weight
[Music]
foreign